for
yeah hello and welcome to our Monday
evening show one hour of Chess hopefully
explained at least I try so let's get
going I'm really happy to start a couple
of five minute games where are we here
five minute yeah I haven't played a
single game of chess today really not no
not a single one nope so I'm happy to
get going hello also to all of you in
the
chat couple of regulars
on and uh yeah let's see do we
have well it's
fairly populated got many tit titled
players
on H don't get a game
though H it looks
pretty full game started now we get one
German sein my sound is pretty pretty l
loud I'm going to turn that down a
little
bit so let's get
going let's going to probably transpose
to a reti
opening
yep and now mostly Bishop E7 or yeah
okay this is
possible so we're going
to turn this into a Tash
probably yep Queen's Gambit
Tash B3 is an interesting
line I C takes and that sit quite
unusual black normally does not want to
take on D4 here as the white control
over this square is uh extremely
good uh Bishop E6 yeah I think just Rook
C1 is good
yep covering that yeah I think White's
position here is quite comfortable I've
got very good control over
D4 and maybe I get
this toight Knight A4 yes I'm going to
do a tter steel recap today for my
channel not for the I
today so night E4 played by German sein
um H interesting I was my intention
was to take on C6 I think I will still
still do that and Bishop
D4 trying
to get this Knight to C5 he he wants to
attack me that's not
nice so let's go to
C5 mhm keeping this yeah so he he wants
to somehow maybe H5 H4 is his
idea yeah thanks for the positive
feedback on the interview that I did on
the Perpetual chess forecast it's a nice
s check it out the other interviews um
are also interesting I've listened to
some of
them so what to do
here I think this is a good diagonal
maybe Queen F3 to F6 is an
idea he's not threatening to play
C5 so I'm going to do that what's the
deal Bishop F5 then
or
maybe
H I don't
know
I'm not quite sure what his plan is to
be honest Queen F3 this bishop F5 I can
go Queen F4 then even that's not
[Music]
bad but not not extremely
convincing I should probably just play a
bit
quicker
Queen F4 Queen E7 not doing
much I don't know I just have to speed
up the position is better
anyway just spend just I just looked at
this for a long while and it didn't
really didn't really net me all that
much
Queen D4 is a very simple
idea so Queen
D4 yeah we have some snow in Germany but
it's it's not a
lot what is he doing here H4 Queen
G4
yeah that's indeed true I played this a
little bit too lame I
think
so double
attacking
stuff well
yeah it's not it's not really ideal but
I have
to now be okay with this simplifications
I think
check as I'm so much down
TimeWise time
check
yeah that should have played that played
that probably
differently that was
bad my position out the opening was
absolutely absolutely great and uh I
didn't get anything out of
it
yeah this is a bit uncomfortable
really things like
that Bishop doesn't have good good safe
squares and the main issue is
that 30 seconds is less than 2
minutes
check I have
to be cautious here that not some sort
of exchange sack is Bishop B4 check yeah
this is what happens there you have no
time okay that was a very very poor game
okay I hope it gets better that was
really beginner beginner like
play game started so okay making no
sense let's go E4 and Checkmate the
guy yeah there was a ban on on chess 24
I I don't
know I didn't follow this uh this all
that much I've played this person who
was banned two times and won uh and won
both games pretty easily uh sorry there
was one draw I'm sorry there was one
draw but out of a completely winning
position I I think in in the games
against me he just played badly I mean I
know that he had had beaten swidler but
uh I did not see those games so I cannot
cannot really um
tell so we have a position here out of
the the
dragon um no it's not it wasn't a dragon
I'm sorry but um we have a dragon St
position that should be probably roughly
equal not sure about B5 why would black
want to Beacon his Queen side it's
probably
not
um nothing decisive but still a bit
surprising
so let's see
F4 trying to gain a bit of space and
then see where that leads
me my KN on C3 I maybe man if I can go
F5 now maybe
B yeah I'm trying
that
interesting oh I actually did not see
this correctly I was thinking I could
play
E5 but I
cannot it's a bit of a
shame didn't see this
correctly
H that I didn't expect that before why
would you do
that
yeah yeah this ending I my pawns are a
little bit
weak Rook 8 to C4
maybe I think E5 yeah he's he's playing
against this this
idea yeah pretty that's pretty
good Rook A5 still Rook C four
probably he can still go Rook C4 I
wanted to play Rook C4 C3 but he can
still take on
e4
yeah Rook 8 C4 is
good not quite sure why he isn't playing
it are moves make little sense but you
never
know if you are called making no sense
what he is going to
do
A4 let's activate this
Rook
yeah it's not a very favorable
structure I have to
say I don't quite understand what's
going on in the chat what is so
interesting about people cheating at
online chats I mean it happens all of
the time there's nothing special about
this
case
B3 will still take
huh what an awful game I really play
badly here in this
session
check yeah King takes what's the
deal B why did what did you do
that
okay
that's a bit
surprising to say the
least
check so now this just has this just has
to run
now I'm a little bit quicker I'm a
little bit quicker
here how to how to do that if I go King
C3 before I'm going
back with the Rook
check doesn't that help
me
H that was a very weird ending I was
absolutely uh worse at the beginning of
it so um what to do is do
now B7 Rook
B8 still have to
be time on the lookout here how to how
to do do
that maybe just go with the King
here all he's just about just about in
time here
H that's not
good I don't manage C4
C5 time wise and they can take there H
that's not
good draw offered check
no simply
not check
check
check check n it is a draw
check check draw offer check draw offer
draw offer black forfeits on time I
tried
sorry not more that I can
do
uh may I should have offered earlier but
um yeah
anyway that game didn't really deserve a
winner um okay let's go for a new one
Lorenzo
Mech um let's go
E5 my uh opinion on the gron Feld sure
it's a good opening it depends a little
bit on what level you're going to intend
to employ it on a higher level it it's
really lots of work due to the enormous
amount of forcing lines that are that
are um
available and uh on on a lower level
this is not so much of a
problem because both sides probably
won't know the theory
perfectly and then you just play the
position and the grunfeld is a very
Dynamic interesting opening
so here white was extremely greedy
taking like every Pawn that was uh
possible to
take I don't believe in this uh way of
playing much
but still people do it people are
greedy what's what's going on here is
Bishop B four a good move
here I don't know let's
just is that blundering a bishop it
does it does okay I have to push the H
Pawn Yeah my rating is not all that
great I've played a couple of bad games
recently
and uh that that doesn't
help it does not
help so what's going on
here just try to be as active as
possible I'm a couple of Pawns down two
Pawns in
fact that's the kind of move that you
don't
expect check anyway let's take
it Queen G5 is normal
just get
the most activity
possible and now what's what's on what's
going on
here
[Music]
uh what's going on here yeah the Knight
to F the Knight has to
come Knight to F4 or something like
that why couldn't he take
H5 G2 was
hanging could he take it later
maybe um okay so what's going
on ag3 or not I don't
no I feel I need a knight on on F4
here Knight will come to E4 which is
extremely annoying here but
okay
let's think about this for a
moment yeah Knight E4 I cannot really
take E3 was hanging he couldn't have
taken the bishop on
B7
I wanted to play Queen to
E7
but he's got Knight
F5 F5
coming tough but f five is
coming maybe he has to play Knight
F5 Knight F4
though
tough very tough tough position I'm
happy that he at least thinks for a
moment and not plays instant moves the
whole
time so I can actually think about this
for a little
bit so Knight F5 I
probably go Knight
F4 and I have F5 F
what and don't give me that that move
works
wow
oops so what's going on here
um Knight
E2 our
F5 ah come on I I I'll go for that I
know he can check me but
um he
doesn't okay I'm keeping this
then how is this going to be played
Queen G5 is a
possibility or various
sacrifices the computer will totally
love it you after this game like are you
are you insane because there are
probably so many things missed here that
you
can can barely count so Queen G5 I was
thinking it should be the right
Square so if I take it he cannot take
with the Knight he has to take with the
[Music]
queen
but it doesn't do
much
okay this threatens
ag3 which he
covered can still not
take time warning
Knight D7 is an extremely cheeky
move
extremely cheeky
move like I don't
care
huh
I just have four seconds is the problem
position is now winning but 4 seconds
won't do
it
check
check black or fits
on story of my Blitz
Games
great
okay game started let's go for a new
game I was only like three queens up
last game not Len and if I'm below 2,300
I feel like a complete um don't don't
say
[Laughter]
it at least I feel like I'm doing
badly so not Len we get
a reverse
benoni
so yeah I'm trying to get B4 in here in
this
Boni and I probably
will I am playing faster this
game not sure if it helps
but that's the first uh goal in this
game just play
faster wow
that looks very
strange feels like uh White is
completely
overextended oh maybe maybe he's got
Knight
E5
I can take here
right if I'm not winning this game I
probably should uh really switch to some
some other game yeah
play play something uh
simpler
yeah what position type do I prefer V
ULU UI
asks um I prefer position with good
control this is really what I would
answer
there I I like to have positions where I
feel I have
um a good grasp what's going on I don't
like
chaos
all that
much black resigned
yes got a win
in bit L bit late but uh okay North
Hampshire North
Hampshire so let's be
quick okay
I don't like F5 all that much but it is
playable main goal is play
quickly
so let's get it to B7 it's a little bit
unusual here we can go
A6 okay at least the queen side is close
then H maybe you still should do
it yeah you know I also like reports
games but it's a different thing
watching something or doing it yeah it's
a it's the same thing with with the with
other areas in life yeah doing something
or yeah watch other people do it is a
different
matter okay so he wants to
trade
no I probably wouldn't have been that
bad to trade but I want to check M him
however weird that may sound but I
try with F4 here we go it's already
going E4
here but one thing I know I'm not going
to lose on time this
position
so yeah I can put the Rook
back when I wonder I probably will do
that it's just
annoying going for Knight
H4
Knight F5 G3 stuff like
that yeah maybe white is better but it
doesn't doesn't feel terrible for me at
least first impression yeah I think
Bishop Bishop Bishop back is a self pin
yeah I probably have to do
this it's not that bad okay but now my
knight is coming
back um now E4 comes into consideration
opening up that
diagonal I think I'm going to do
that
yeah it was a tragic game today report
uh with black against Wesley so that was
one of the luckiest
win I um I've witnessed in in recent
times I
mean so really got totally killed by
report and uh yeah all of a sudden he
won the game out of really out of
nowhere so what's going on here let's
take
this
and yeah get the Knight near the king
maybe I'm getting checkmated here with
some Knight E6 stuff or
so but
um don't quite believe it I'm still add
on the clock after playing this yeah you
know move first think later
Style
huh so he just ignores
it going for G7 himself
yeah makes some
sense maybe just Queen E8 in this
position h
have to get get
rolling E3 is attacked B7 hangs but
things get messy
now okay so he wants to go Queen H5 I
guess
I was thinking Knight E5 maybe I can
also take here with the bishop am I
threatening direct maid or stuff
no but I can take
there and there
so let's do
this queen H5 shouldn't work he just
take the pawn wow he just grabs the pawn
of all
things Rook F1 no then he can probably
really sa the
queen
wow
a queen takes this Knight
F7 so I have to take with this
oh that that's not
good
I'm really getting killed in this game
what a freaking
shame and against someone that I usually
always beat this is extremely
bad got a 100% score against this
person but that doesn't help in this
particular game I don't have a move
here strengths Queen takes
H4
unbelievable yeah it's just lost what
what can you do it just lost this
game
yeah it's certainly was okay at one
point at least okay
but
now Knight F7
wins he's not doing this
well
check
Knight F7 is still winning no now I can
actually take it
check Rook d8 Queen
d8
check
check I'm getting m i don't believe this
nonsense
now Queen
eight what a joke no my oh my God any
move any move but Queen G6 fors on time
ah
no ah I'm such an idiot I'm just a green
up
here I can play H6 or
whatever
okay
ah yeah I had a I had a a bad feeling
for this session you know and now he
moves H6 yeah I know that I'm winning
here with every move besides the one
that I played you don't need to rub it
in and I had I had 19 seconds at the end
you know I could have looked at the I
could have looked at this yeah just look
at it game can even go back or something
and now that's time for the king's
Gambit or stuff something
crazy normal normal chest doesn't work
quite
obviously
so yeah that's what happens yeah you get
a crap position if you play if you play
uh weird
stuff let's
see that already looks pretty
awful so what's going on here it looks
very bad
actually so D3 Knight G5
hm the Knight has little
squares wow it's a pretty awful
position
check at least I got
castled so um what's going
on
that's
bad tried to bring the bishop over to F4
at
least on B2 it is is just having a
really bad
position
so at least this looks good I'm happy
that he doesn't have a knight yeah
Knight somewhere around my king would be
the end of the game it looks um tricky
anyway F5
wow m
that I didn't really have on the
radar okay I I will open this
up
um
okay
yeah so he's trying to take it like
that and will probably manage
yeah that's really well played by
black yeah he's playing this this quite
well
Queen C6 you probably will
play
now I don't really care so much about
the r in in itself it just that it
reflects how good how bad I play and if
I play badly I feel badly and I want to
want to do better because I know that
this is not a rating that I should have
if I'm playing um in in normal
form um I'm just I'm just a bit better
than
2,200 so yeah this looks absolutely
terrible I need to do something here
it's um
yeah just extremely passive this
position the whole opening result was
absolutely absolutely
bad okay so um
yeah
okay not sure that this helped
him
H
okay
check if I if I get if I would get on
the eile I Rook e one actually now this
is this is getting somewhat
interesting okay okay he attacks
this but check I have I have a couple of
checks Rook
E7 then back there yeah
check King King uh A8 Queen to
B3 threatening or this one yeah but here
I should have at least a
draw and maybe I've got more
but more more seems a little bit
unrealistic
so going to check give give some checks
first
check time warning
check
that that that uh should still be a draw
but he has to be a bit careful
here
I queen what
no no no no no no that's not going to
work
check threatens
made a five this queen
E6 or queen D4 it's actually made in two
already that was a that was a suicide
mission really
check check me hey that was a total
suicide
mission what he did
now okay let's let's uh go for a new
game maybe I can at least restore the
2,300
which is kind of the
minimum yeah I think he he had he he
needed to draw here and it was certainly
possible here Queen to D2 should be a
draw I
think okay that that must be a
draw
check and maybe maybe I can actually win
this huh
Check N I'm not completely sure about
this ending so I've got a new game
request
out
so
yeah I've won the I won the white games
no that are also lost
yeah pretty bad
result game started again North
Hampshire that's the guy who uh yeah
yeah yeah
yeah we we'll we'll see about that I'll
play the same stuff again and now I'm
going to Checkmate
you just playing
better
for
yeah my idea is Bishop H3 Knight G4 and
mate and I'm not going to do anything
else
here Knight G4 it's pretty bit too
much
okay Knight F5 or Knight
G4 yeah let's go Knight G4 I mean Bishop
D6 I'm I'm taking
G3 check should
should
work so if you're defending the this
position I will be a little
bit I will be a little bit
unfriendly it looks extremely dangerous
Mr North
Hampshire
okay I'm not going to think here I'm
just playing this
moves so Bishop takes E7 is what he's
going to do
or
he has to dig on seven I guess I mean
for better worse he has to do
it
okay come
on
that's the full standard program
here the typical checkmating
pattern it should be lost I mean how
does he defend this stuff Bishop
E7 Bishop F3 maybe just
this or Rook F3 or something I mean they
they should
win Rook takes F3 pre
this this one I
guess okay Rook F3 King G2
can't even play Knight E3 check that's a
complete
disaster
um check yeah it's enough I don't I
don't just need one
win
Queen H3 should be
the should be
decisive or do we have something
quicker I can just take that but okay
this is
good
Rook F2 I'm
taking G3 I
guess white resign doesn't allow me this
the end to the end of the game so this
this is how it ends check check
threatening
made and that's it basically I was
actually thinking this is made but there
is this this bishop still so I have to
do something like that but by now I've
got like extra extra
everything okay I think I go for one
more game I'm
just I just want
to end this with another game maybe I
can win three in a
row and we have a couple of good guys on
there some high rated players but my own
rating is down so I'm not
um um I'm not going to be paired against
the stronger guys all that
often got
uh Julian hon on for
example
got the request
out King's Gambit game started I've got
black so you want something sharp now
let's see what we can drum up maybe he's
playing the king's Gambit no he
doesn't H it's tough to get get
something really sharp against this I
can play something wcky like Queen H4
but I don't really want to
yeah here black can just develop
normally
castles Rook e
eight he takes on B6 this this Pawn
structure is actually quite nice for
black mean not like an advantage but
it's quite
nice you control many crucial
squares and sometimes you even get in
Rook A5 yeah use the Rook on the fifth
rank
F4 is a bit
surprising to
me looks a little bit weakening but
maybe sorry maybe the activity is just
more
important huh okay I wonder if this is a
good move not sure about it
or is he just playing with
C4 maybe
C4
yeah I can he might also just take I'm
not quite sure what the long thought is
all
about C4 I don't know D D5
Maybe
H it's a little bit strange
or he doesn't have a good connection I'm
still connected I hope yeah
huh a little bit weird what ancient is
doing
here his engine crashed I don't think so
I have played him two times before 2 one
those
games H it's a bit
weird I was hoping for fight forfeits
due to
disconnection that's
bad H that's a bit of a sad end of this
session okay like one more
game I don't want to end it like that
it's a bit sad
maybe give me one of the higher rated
guys vog is on I think that's and dra
okay let's go play against grandmas
arada aradi Rodin I don't even know what
he's playing he's playing the Caro
okay okay I play the two knights I don't
think there's
um anything funky that I can do
him and this is a very solid
line that he's playing
here
check Bishop H6 isn't that a problem
maybe he's checking me and then Queen H
five
no
okay seems he doesn't care all that
much maybe he's castling
long maybe Knight E5 is an idea here
Knight E5 Bishop D1 Bishop F6 seven
Checkmate it's quite
funny but he will play probably Knight
D7 now
anyway um I have Queen B3 here though
this is
interesting trying to make his Bishop
look a bit bit bad
there
even Knight G5 is technically all I can
take it take it
Knight H okay I'm trying
this ah B7 is hanging also so I I only
see that now which is really late
um so um I'll take this then
right grab this grab this
Pawn also makes his
further castling a little bit
unclear I mean it's unclear how he going
to Castle this is what I was trying to
say and not quite succeeded
with so here what's going
on I would like to I would like to put
something on the eile and threaten Rook
takes
E6 long castling is an extremely cool
move
here but
it feels like it shouldn't work
really so I could Castle short there
[Music]
instead
long castling I'm kind
of would love to play that
move Why didn't it
work Queen B6 or queen B8 this isn't
okay if it doesn't work I don't know
it's not all that important it's just a
Blitz
game
main idea is Rook E1 Rook takes E6
so he probably will play I know maybe
Rook B6 he takes the
pawn what the
heck ah because because of the check
because this is a
check
aha ahuh I
understand
okay okay um H maybe F4
now yeah the thing is Queen A5 is going
to threaten
stuff as
well yeah anyway let's do
it but Queen A5 I don't really see what
I'm doing
then I can do this but then then Queen
A3
hits
what a
shame it must have been such a good
position at the
beginning that move that it looked so
wacky that move but I couldn't resist it
long
castles I should have just played
something normal but uh it was it was
tough to
resist yeah and unfortunately this is
working I cannot I cannot cover
everything Rook C2 the mates on C2 E2
and everything at the same
time ah
okay white resigns what a
shame yeah Round Here black is certainly
busted I should play something normal
here and just win the game
this for example is probably just
winning I mean he's totally tied down
but I couldn't resist couldn't resist
castling long it was such a Bonkers
looking move and it was bad
yeah uh Rook D2 is still playable
but yeah it's not what you want he Queen
A5 wins okay that was a bit too much
thanks for watching guys I hope you
enjoyed the session bit of an up and
down down struggle in this one I'll be
back next week thanks for
watching